in this video I'm going to talk about
drug elimination and bioavailability
also I'm going to talk about hepatic
first bus effect so what is
bioavailability the word bio
availability availability the world
bioavailability means fraction of drug
fraction of drug that is available in
the system extrapolation in the system
in circulation and that is independent
of the route of administration
so fraction of draw a drug that is
available in the system makes our
circulation after administration is
known as bioavailability of a particular
drug so here we would draw a diagram and
we would take a look at two routes of
administration one is oral and one is
intravenous and we would see how the
bioavailability differs for these two
paths so here I'm drawing a simplified
diagram for a heart so here is the
simplified diagram for our heart and say
for instance this is our liver this is
all liver and here is our hepatic
so he was all liver and here is our
hepatic artery and we have here our
hepatic vein and also here we have the
intestine
and from indice tine to liver we have
the hepatic portal vein partic portal
vein and this is the hepatic artery this
is the hepatic portal vein this is the
hepatic vein and so this is a systemic
circulation and this is the portal
circulation so when our drug such as
this tablet is as administered or in the
oral route so it would go into the gut
and it would be absorbed into the
intestine when it is absorbed in the
intestine it would go straight via this
hepatic portal vein to deliver and in
liver biotransformation of the drug
would happen and a drug would become
more solubilized by addition of a series
of reaction phase one and Phase two
biocon biotransformation reaction and
that would be excreted in the urine so
before getting available into the body
in the systemic circulation
the drug is eliminated by the liver so
this effect is called first pass effect
in contrast if we see another mode of
administration that is our IV
administration that means intravenous
administration then our drug is directly
available into the systemic circulation
this odd drug is directly available in
the system in circulation in contrast
our oral route the drug is not that much
available in the system except relation
because liver eliminates the drug a lot
portion of the drug is eliminated by the
liver so here we are trying to draw a
graph and try to visualize how
availability of the drug affected in
case of oral administration and IV
administration for instance it is our
oral administration so
we have time in the x-axis and we have
the drug concentration on the y axis so
this is for our oral administration and
here is the C Max value for the oral
administration in contrast for IV
administration the drug would be more
available to the body so the drug have a
higher C max value in contrast to the so
this this would be for oral
administration
and this would be for ivy administration
so bioavailability for the IV
administration would be far greater than
the drug which is administered orally
now we will try to see the kinetics of
elimination of drug elimination so our
drug elimination kinetics could be
broadly divided into two categories one
is first order elimination and other is
the zeroth order elimination so let's
see the first order elimination we say
for instance we have a drug
concentration of C so the first order
differential equation would be DC DT
would be some constant over C so the
elimination is dependent upon
concentration so it is written as DC DT
equal to minus KC so now if we just do
the math and if we integrate it from c0
to CT where CT is the drug concentration
after a time T and C 0 is the initial
drug concentration and we integrate it
over time 0 to T we would have a line
that is natural log C T C 0 equal to
minus K T and if we just analyze and
rearrange it we would have CT by C 0
equal to e to the power minus KT and CT
CT would be C 0 e to the power minus KT
or we can write it as e to the power KT
so from this equation it is quite
evident that drug concentration at time
T is less than a the initial
concentration so the concentration of
the drug is less at time T and that is
the sense of elimination so if we just
draw the graph for that or the first
order elimination if we try to draw the
graph and this is time and this is drug
concentration I mean concentration is C
so what would happen with the
increase of time the drug concentration
would fall so this is the first order
elimination reaction in contrast if we
have a zero with order so this is our
first order elimination if we have our
zero eight order elimination then our
elimination rate rate of elimination
that is DC DT is independent of the
concentration term so our DC DT is
actually our constant
so DC DT would be constant now if we try
to draw the graph of drug concentration
over time then it would be a straight
line so it's actually doesn't depend
upon the concentration of the drug so
for the first order kinetics if we have
more drug in our body in our system then
the rate of elimination would be faster
but in contrast if we have for the zero
order the drugs that follow zero order
kinetics if we have greater amount of
those drugs and that drugs won't be
eliminated very easily because they
would be eliminated at a fairly constant
rate their rate of elimination is
constant say for example the zeroth
order drugs zero order drugs are
alcohols
alcohols
so alcohols follow these zero order
kinetics and what happens say for
instant we have 100 ml of alcohol and
the elimination rate is 10 ml per hour
so to eliminate the whole amount of
alcohol we need at least 10 hour time to
eliminate the whole alcohol apart from
alcohol many other drug also follow the
0th order kinetics but it is quite
harmful because the drug stays for a lot
of period in the body so it could result
in a huge amount of toxicity whereas if
we talk about a zero order kinetics the
drug elimination is quite faster with
respect to our zero at order kinetics
the first-order kinetics in the first
order kinetics the drug elimination is
quite faster and just to summarize the
hepatic first pass effect
hepatech first pass effect should be
considered as a very important fact
because many drugs
we cannot be administered in the oral
route because of this hepatic first pass
effect for example morphine cannot be
administered in the oral route because
most of the administer most of the
administered morphine would be
eliminated by the liver and this by
morphine have to be administered by the
IV route instead of the oral route hope
you liked it have enjoyed and please
like and don't forget to subscribe